recently our friends at prageru have put
out a video called
did capitalism save communist china
having studied chinese history at
university this of course beat my
interest
how did one of the world's poorest
countries china
become in 30 years one of the world's
richest
there is one word answer capitalism
here's how it happened in 1949
the chinese communist party aka the ccp
defeated the nationalist party in the
brutal civil war
the leader of the ccp mao zedong
promised the chinese people
that he would create a new china a
socialist paradise
where the benevolent state would take
care of
every citizen's needs from shelter to
education
to employment no more greedy businessmen
factories would be owned by their
workers no more evil landowners
the state would own all property on
behalf of the people
no more hunger everyone could eat as
much as they want at the public
cafeterias
to transform china into this heaven on
earth
mao launched radical socialist reforms
okay so before we go any further let's
not let prageru play around with the
terms
socialism means one thing collective
ownership of the means of production
that's it however people on the right
seem to think that communism and
socialism
equal government do thing now there can
be different variants of socialism such
as market socialism democratic socialism
tldr it's complicated and so maoist
china
lasted from 1949 until 1978
mao having died in 1976. in the two
years that followed until 1978
real power in china was held by hua
guofeng who was mao's designated
successor
only to be pushed out of power in 1978
by deng xiaoping who was considered to
be a reformist
now between 1949 and 1978 quite the
number of things
happened for the sake of brevity the
most important and relevant ones were
of course the great leap forward between
1958 and 1960
and then the correction between 1960 and
1966
a brief period of chaos and infighting
between 1966 and 1968
an internal culture war between young
radicals and an older technocratic
establishment
during which the gang of four rose to
prominence this was between 1972 and
1976
followed by the death of mao of course
and an internal coup against the gang of
four
resulting among other things in the
political rehabilitation of deng
xiaoping in 1977 only to have him assume
power one year later in 1978
thus marking the end of the maoist era
now what i just told you is just a teeny
tiny fraction of the totality of maui's
china's history
and so how does prageru account for this
long and complex
era speaking of food it wasn't long
after mao took power
that the widespread food shortages began
happening my own parents had to get up
at
3 o'clock in the morning to stand in
long lines outside of a grocery store
to get a pound of sugar or several
ounces of cooking oil
often they got nothing every year was
worse
than the last between 1958
and 1962 china experienced the worst
famine in human history an estimated
45 million chinese starved to death
victims of their own government's
murderous stupidity
among the lives lost were my uncle my
grand-aunt and her family of five
and my dad's maternal grandmother
at the time of mouse death in 1976
more than 90 percent of the chinese
population
lived below the poverty line earning
less than two dollars a day
the only equality socialism had achieved
was a equal
distribution of misery mao's successor
deng xiaoping recognized that this
couldn't go on much longer
the only way to save the ccp's one-party
rule
was to get the economy going but how
dung had no idea fortunately for him
a small group of farmers did in 1978
these farmers 18 of them in the village
of xiaogang
made a secret deal with your village
leader
after fulfilled in the government quotas
they would be allowed to keep
any surplus for themselves and sell what
they didn't need
such a move was risky because it was a
rejection
of the ccp's socialist policies but the
result was magical
the first year after this deal went into
effect
the 18 farmers produced more grain
than the entire village had produced in
the previous 10 years combined
the xiaogang model began to spread to
other villages
when didn't heard of it rather than
punish the farmers
he had a good sense to recognize that
this simple peasants
had shown him how to revive china's
economy
soon after dung announced the sweeping
economic reforms
he opened up china to the outside world
inviting foreign investments
and most importantly loosening the
government's grip
on the chinese people according to
prageru
mao came to power in 1949 did socialism
for a while this caused a big starvation
and then 16 years later in 1978
some brave farmers figured out
capitalism and started doing it in spite
of the communist system
and the new leader was wise enough to
see that what the farmers were doing was
working and so he adapted it and it
became a
nationwide economic policy i guess thus
catapulting china into world prominence
and prosperity
alright so what's wrong with breaker use
analysis well
what's not wrong with it alright first
point deng xiaoping had no idea how to
do reforms and so he had to turn to the
farmers
alright so this is the 50 iq
kindergartner explanation
deng xiaoping's reform process actually
went on for decades
consisting of careful experimentation
and incrementalism
the reform process was officially
launched in december 1978
on the third plenum of the chinese
communist party's ninth central
committee
the central tenets of the dengueist
economic reforms became the
so-called four modernizations meaning
industry
agriculture science and defense and the
official goal of these policies was to
create
socialism with chinese characteristics
and of course it's ludicrous to assert
that deng xiaoping worked alone
in reality the entire chinese
establishment was behind him working on
the reforms
and so the reform process itself had
three main sections
the first one was the countryside
section between 1978 and 1984
the second one was the urban section
between 1984 and 1991 and the third one
was the complex synchronized reform
efforts between 1992 and 2000
which brought together all the previous
reforms thus creating the basis of
today's modern china
this is an extremely difficult complex
multiple decade long reform process
it was by no means deng xiaoping
personally coming up with the answer of
oh yeah it's free market capitalism huh
these farmers figured it out damn
the results were nothing less than
astonishing
the freer the chinese economy became the
wealthier the chinese people became
in the space of three decades 800
million chinese people emerged out of
poverty
chinese cities now match and exceeds the
greatest
cities of the west skyscraper for
skyscraper
the ccp likes to pat itself on the back
for china's economic miracle
however the real credit should go to
free market
capitalism and 18 brave farmers
who risk their lives to give it a try
alright second point in terms of china's
meteoric rise as an economic powerhouse
credit goes to free market capitalism
and the 18 brave farmers
well according to prageru anyway you may
or may not be surprised to learn but
this point has already been debunked by
someone
that's right it's time for prageru to
face a worthy opponent
namely prageru western europe shot up as
well but later
it rose steadily during the industrial
revolution and then experienced a sharp
rise after world war
ii when between the end of the war and
the mid-1960s
it fully embraced the free market japan
too shot up after world war ii
surpassing western europe for the first
time
after the u.s helped the japanese
transition to a democracy
and a free-market capitalist economy
eastern europe took off after it was
released from the soviet union and
socialism in 1991.
china did likewise after the chinese
moved away from strict socialism
and implemented some limited free market
policies
that's right according to prageru
socialism with limited free market
policies
can produce such astonishing results you
convinced me man let's do socialism in
the us with limited free market policies
let's make america great again i mean if
it worked in china it will work in the
us
am i right i mean damn it's almost like
prageru doesn't actually believe in
anything and they just use this platform
to
cynically peddle the agenda of their
billionaire handlers
anyway prageru goes on to close the
video with this
in recent years china's growth has
slowed
precisely because the current ccp
leadership
has moved back to a model that asserts
ever more
government control the country is
becoming less free with each passing
year
the ccp uses technology such as facial
recognition
surveillance cameras and control of the
internet
to monitor its citizens every move
more and more there are signs that the
ccp is reverting to its mao is the past
that's bad for china and bad for the
world
i'm helen rowley author of confucius
never said
for prager university wait did you catch
that
sneaky breaker you you almost slipped by
me
did you see what they did there they
began by saying socialism is a set of
economic policies that it was something
bad adopted by a totalitarian government
but by the end of the video they go on
to say that socialism
is the totalitarianism so essentially
its government do thing
and this is prageru's true position and
it only took them five and a half
minutes to arrive at
neet but the problems causing china's
slowing economic growth is not
government do thing the issue is
actually much more complex than that
you might be surprised to learn problems
include social and wealth inequality
environmental damage both caused or
exacerbated by free market policies by
the way
demographic problems the geopolitical
environment
a middle class growing more and more
conscious these are china's real issues
not government do thing but
unfortunately prageru is not paid to
tell the truth
they're paid to tell us this disney-fied
version of history
where the free market freedom-loving
good guys face off against the
pro-communist pro-socialist neo-marxist
feminist
bad people who just would not let the
good guys make the world a better place
and man i i just wish the world was this
simple but of course unfortunately it's
not
and it's pretty unfair too i mean it
took me hours to dig up my
old university notes to look through my
old
chinese history notes so i can provide
an accurate and
like rounded take on the whole chinese
history issue
whereas sprigger you can just stand up
there and just start spouting [ __ ] and
millions of people will just believe
them oh well the battle goes on
thank you for watching and please like
and subscribe and i'll be seeing you
when i'll see you